quand il est interdit d'aller au marché
c'est le marché qui vient à vous c'est
une première pour emmanuel bono
habituellement vendeuses sur les marchés
elle est depuis ce matin devenu livres
de produits frais à domicile
[Musique]
au programme de la tournée aujourd'hui
une quinzaine de clients la livraison
permet d'écouler une partie du stock des
fruits et des légumes bio d'ordinaire
vendus sur le marché de maurepas les
clients eux sont évidemment ravis de
pouvoir accéder à des produits frais
tout en restant à la maison je tenais
absolument dans la mesure du possible à
avoir toujours des produits frais a pas
être obligé de manger que des conserves
des pâtes du riz
donc c'est très important d'avoir des
produits frais c'est aussi important de
les faire continuer à travailler
travailler en respectant les règles
sanitaires pour sa première tournée de
livraison emmanuel prend toutes les
précautions d'usagé
donc ça fait ma belle-mère confectionner
c'est une règle d'hygiène pour moi ça me
protège de ça rassure les clients les
grands pareil la machine à carte bleue
qui va être des enfants
après chaque livraison c'était
surprenant de nouveau avec des masques
ou des choses comme ça mais pour
satisfaire l'ensemble de ses clients aux
yvelinois la firme de là et prévoit
plusieurs livraisons par semaine
radis salades des poireaux viendront
jusqu'à vous le temps du confinement